you see the toyota numbers not pretty
for steven matz this year but what is
pretty
are his career numbers against the
atlanta braves 14 starts six and two
with a 2.83
freddy is roasting hot an 11-game
hitting streak
freddie shoots this one a second cano
olays it and it's into shallow right
field
and atlanta's got runners at first and
third would nobody out and marcelo zuno
and a broken bat little pop into shallow
right fields going to score the game's
first run
conforto is going to fire toward third
the throw is going to be
late freeman got in ahead of the fraser
tag
and he says take a look at video frazier
says that freeman slid right on top of
his glove
no matter how you score that play it's a
broken bad hit for ozuna and the braves
have scored the first run
at the moment outrunning that throw to
third
by michael conforto but the mets are
going to take a look here we're seeing
the replay now
and frazier actually blocked the bag so
freeman
is going to be out at third here he
never got to third base
that's an excellent job by frazier he
had his right foot right in front of the
bag
and freeman slid into it knocked
frazier's foot into the base
and the replay review has signaled out
at third
freeman is retired and that's a big
first out for the mets
here's austin riley with the bases
loaded and riley takes strike three
called he dropped a curve ball on him
and matt
minimizes the first inning damage max
freed who enters this game jeff
a perfect 6-0 on the year and
his 1.69 road era is the second best
among starting pitchers in major league
baseball
as jeff mcneal will go to work against
max fried who pitches for the first time
since the fifth of september
the first one is on the ground to
freddie welcome back max freed
a ground ball out at 93 miles an hour so
freed will go from the stretch
facing michael conforto davis a very
short lead at first and the o2 pitch
strike three takes care of conforto on
three pitches and max freed paints a
corner two hours todd frazier is the
cleanup man for the mets
breaking ball slowly hit freed pounces
spins settles fires a strike
to first in a very impressive 10 pitch
first inning
for max freed he gives up a one-out walk
and that is all it's one-nothing atlanta
and the braves again are in business
marcakus and acuna on freddie freeman
is up stephen matt's piling up the
pitches and freddie shoots
down the right field line fair and
headed for the corner marquez the lead
runner is going to come around and score
here comes acuna ronald is on his way
home he's going to score standing up and
freddie freeman does it again
he's two for two against the mets and
mats tonight
and ozuna the batter he has the other
rbi hit for the braves
two pitches tomahawk deep to left field
and it is gone into the second deck
a two-run homer for marcelo zuna he's
got three rbis
he's tied for the league lead and homers
and the braves have busted the game open
it's five
nothing robinson can know the banner
base is empty for canoe
and that swung on and missed big slow
curve ball and robbie didn't get it
and max freed has his took second
strikeout
third strike with the bases loaded to
end the first inning
hit high in the air to center field and
deep racing back mariznick at the wall
gives up it's gone for riley
into the right center field placards
eighth home run of the season for austin
reilly
and a great start to the braves third
inning second home run off mats
six to nothing atlanta perfect night for
ozona continues he's aboard in front of
darneau
perfect night for darno he is singled
and walked
and this one hit high in the air toward
left field that ball
is going to go for darneau another homer
for the braves the eighth for darneau
two more on the board for the bravos
it's eight to nothing the former met
comes to his former home and makes him
pay
eight runs on nine hits three walks in
the inning
runners at first and second and two out
for nick markkakis who has single and
struck out
two on pitch here's a fly ball hit
towards center mariznick on his horse
won't get it it's over his head
duval scores riley is on his way to
third he's going to streak around and
score and the braves are putting a
hurting on kiliman
well what a way to start los bravos
weekend atlanta has scored 10 runs on 10
hits
and now ozzie hits one high in the air
toward right center mariznick back to
the track at the wall leaping try can't
get that
ozzy hits a home run another two run
homer for the braves
mcneal rips one down the line he's got
to base it
rosario on his way to third they're
going to wave him around as marcakis
plays it out of the corner
and the mets finally get on the board
jeff mcneal with an rbi double and it's
12-1
so now conforto 0-2 pitch a
struck him out on three pitches the rbi
hit just made him mad max fried is
qualified for a seventh win he leads by
11.
ozzie launches again conforto will turn
and admire this one how far is that
going
out by the shea bridge a two-homer game
for ozzy albees
and ozuna's serenading him as he makes
his way around third round washington as
well and
ozzy albees has come out of the gate a
new man how many nine-hole hitters you
see that have
usually two home run games not much so
it shows you this
graves offense is so deep ozzie gets
another pitch up in the zone
and it's his fifth career marty home run
game for the second baseman
and number 13 is up ronald cuny
and jr hits one high in the air center
maris nick is going to watch that one
sail out of here
bombs away for the braves tonight in new
york
wow 12 homers for acuna
and you know ian anderson is saying okay
guys save me a couple tomorrow please
and look at freddie giving a little high
five the off day
seems to have done ronald some good and
i know the matt's
double was off the hanging curve ball
what i like to see here is a
right-hander it's got a good sinker
and ronald that's where he's got so much
power opposite field
great hall's in a strike and ender
shoots one toward right center that's
gonna get down
and around third is riley he will beat
the throw to the plate an rbi hit for
ander and ciarte conforto one for four
has struck out twice
this one up the middle ozzy will step on
the bag he'll throw to first
that is a game ending double play and
this one's in the books the braves
have taken care of the mets 15-2 jeff
they blast
six home runs